we're
finally headed to the good place it's
the me of places
i i got in i can say stuff like that
again are you sure we're going the right
way jenny
well i've never been to the good place
before but
yes i'm sure how
because it feels like i'm on my way home
flying puppy you're almost there just a
little further
flying puppies dang it michael why
didn't you think of that for your
neighborhood
these guys are good
[Music]
i feel just like dorothy when she lands
at us
excited incredulous much
taller than everyone else around me
what's everyone want to do first
racing go-karts with monkeys sure it's
my lifelong dream monkeys are the ideal
go-kart opponents they're funny enough
to give the finger
but not smart enough to win
[Music]
does that mean me you're a good janet
and we're in the good place i don't know
who else it would be
okay no pressure i was born to do this
not born
[Music]
okay so i now know all the information
about the good place in a nutshell
it slaps first thing to tell you humans
can't see the good place all at once
or their brains will be scrambled cool
maybe i'll finally get some of those
squigglies on my brain
doctors said my brain's as smooth as an
egg you will need to wait out here for a
bit so you can adjust
when you're ready you will be honored
with a welcome gala magically planned by
the good place based on your
personalities
like the targeted instagram ad of
parties
you know i bought the coolest sunglasses
from one of those ads
look whoa it's like i'm inside the
internet okay could we just keep moving
you look a little pale did you get sick
from the hot air balloon i bet if you
throw up it'll just be butterflies or
something
i'm fine i just um i don't belong here
there's no telling what will happen to a
demon who steps foot in this place
promise me if i'm vaporized you guys
just keep having fun
oh my goodness that chime is so soothing
it feels like my brain is being massaged
by a baby
oh boy what if that's some sort of demon
alarm to alert the cops that i'm here
you want me to hold your weed i don't
have weed
oh wait a minute oh yeah
okay now i do take this they're ready
for you to move inside
the good place committee is waiting for
us
oh man look at this place
carly kloss did like me i knew it
so about this party is everyone in the
good place invited
like is aristotle gonna be there sorry
chidi aristotle's in the bad place
he defended slavery socrates no too
annoying
very loud chewer plato slavery again
oh you know who is here hypatia of
alexandria do you know her
hypatia of alexandria that's right ah
yeah
i know her
hypocha i'm gonna ask her so many
questions pertaining to grand ideas
about the universe like
why oh oh and also
how oh welcome to the good place
everyone
michael so happy you made it you look
radiant
you have the calming yet authoritative
presence of a bomb sniffing dog
i'd just like to say thank you so much
for letting me be here with my friends
i know it's unorthodox for someone like
myself to visit the good place but it's
just so wonderful and i don't have any
weed on me so no need for the cops
michael michael you and your friends are
heroes and you are more than welcome
here
in fact we have some very exciting news
while the rest of you get settled in
we want to give michael a swearing-in
ceremony so he can become an official
good place architect
huh oh my goodness michael please
follow us holy fork that is
you